bonjour à tous il est midi bienvenue
dans votre édition du 12-13 en Normandie
en direct des Jeux équestres mondiaux
avec ces belles images en ce moment même
de l'épreuve d'endurance une épreuve qui
a débuté depuis 7 heures ce matin autour
de la baie du Mont-Saint-Michel 160 km à
parcourir pour près de 170 cavaliers et
chevaux Florent Turpin bonjour l'épreuve
a débuté très très tôt ce matin oui et
c'est l'un des moments forts de ces 15
jours de compétition regardez c'est
super images il faisait encore nuit ce
matin à l'aube dans la baie du
Mont-Saint-Michel quand les 166
cavaliers venus de 45 pays différents se
sont élancés dans cette épreuve
d'endurance c'est donc parti pour le
jour le plus long de ces Jeux équestres
mondiaux les preuves d'endurance c'est
un marathon équestre qui se déroule sur
une seule journée et regardez une petite
image rigolote dès le départ un cheval a
perdu son cavalier dommage pour lui car
la journée va être très très longue
cette épreuve d'endurance s'étonnez-vous
bien 160 km à parcourir contre la montre
avec des paysages magnifiques des forêts
et bien sûr les plages de la baie du
Mont-Saint-Michel pour décors après un
départ au galop pour éviter les bouchons
les cavaliers doivent ensuite gérer
leurs efforts j'irai leurs chevaux c'est
pourquoi régulièrement ses chevaux
doivent s'arrêter quand c'est possible
c'est pas toujours le cas regardez pour
subir des contrôles vétérinaires
obligatoires on verra ça plus en détail
tout à l'heure les grandes stars de
l'endurance ce sont les cavaliers du
Qatar les Qataris qui ont privilégié ce
matin un départ en équipe mais pour
l'instant ce sont deux concurrents des
Émirats arabes unis qui sont en tête
l'arrivée finale de cette épreuve
d'endurance Erwan sévère 20h tout à
l'heure va suivre ça merci Florent pour
ces très belles images effectivement
mais il faut le rappeler l'endurance
peut-être une discipline dangereuse ce
matin aux alentours de 8h30 une
cavalière du Costa Rica à lourdement
chuté à l'issue de la première boucle
Claudia Romero chacone a dû être
transporté à l'hôpital son cheval lui
n'a pas survécu à la chute après avoir
semble-t-il heurté un arbre on l'a bien
vu sur les images le cadre de ce
marathon de l'équitation et
véritablement un superbe il y a du beau
spectacle en perspective les 5000
billets ont été vendus et il y a même la
possibilité aujourd'hui pour les
spectateurs sans billets d'assister à la
course dans le public depuis la baie de
la pointe du gros un Sud le reportage de
Stéphanie Vinot et de jouer la mare
si l'épreuve d'endurance a été située
dans la région de Sartilly c'est bien
grâce à lui parce qu'il y avait le
Mont-Saint-Michel en décor les
spectateurs avertis ne s'y sont pas
trompés c'est à la pointe du coin du Sud
qui se sont installés il y a un paysage
fantastique en plus bon il y a le
Mont-Saint-Michel derrière nous et là
les chevaux arrivent par deux positions
ils arrivent face à nous et après on se
déplace on les a avec le Mont
Saint-Michel derrière et je crois que
c'est des photos uniques pour nous c'est
idéal invitant la région pour nous la
buse c'est formidable c'était évident de
venir ici les chevaux ont fait un
passage dans ce paysage exceptionnel
pour la deuxième boucle de cette épreuve
qui en compte 5
ce qui est intéressant c'est que on
arrive à approcher les concurrents
d'assez près voir les chevaux on a le
temps de les admirer au passage c'est un
beau spectacle quand on pense qu'ils
vont faire 170 km c'est quand même
impressionnant et les cavaliers par
contre sont assez léger ça m'a surpris
on sait qu'il y aurait plus de gens dans
80 kg donc c'est comme une compétition
qui réservait
à des gens plutôt léger quoi 48 nations
s'affrontent dans la bête du
Mont-Saint-Michel jusqu'à ce soir et les
producteurs de lait du secteur ont
affiché leur préférence
cette épreuve d'endurance est aussi une
preuve sous haute surveillance les
affaires de dopage ont encore récemment
secoué la discipline alors pour ces
Mondiaux la Fédération a choisi de
renforcer les contrôles vétérinaires à
l'un d'entre eux on retrouve tout de
suite Pierre-Marie Puaud c'est l'une des
particularités de l'endurance à
intervalle régulier toutes les heures et
demie environ les chevaux passent entre
les mains d'un vétérinaire le wed
tchèque comme on dit en anglais n'est
pas une simple formalité tout est
extrêmement codifiée les chevaux entrent
d'abord dans la cooling zone où les
grooms refroidissent l'animal essaye de
faire tomber son rythme cardiaque qui
doit impérativement descendre sous les
65 pulsations par minute et puis les
chevaux peints entre les mains d'un des
12 vétérinaires officiels que l'on
aperçoit derrière moi ce n'est pas une
simple formalité là encore le
vétérinaire contrôle l'état de santé
général de l'animal son rythme cardiaque
une fois encore ces allures et le
vétérinaire a le pouvoir d'exclure un
concurrent d'exclure un cheval de le
sortir de la course lever de chat qui
est une sorte de garde-fou en quelque
sorte qui invite le cavalier à ménager
sa monture sur les pistes à protéger la
santé de l'animal la pose dure 40
minutes au total c'est un temps qui est
décompté au classement final 40 minutes
de pause pendant lequel le cheval se
fait cajoler avant de s'élancer à
nouveau dans la course
merci Pierre-Marie l'endurance et
jusqu'à 20h ce soir Florent on passe au
dressage journée off ce jeudi après le
sacre britannique hier regardez c'est ma
chouchoute hein c'était hier au stade
d'Ornano nouveau podium pour l'une des
grandes stars de ces jeux équestre
mondiaux sans surprise Charlotte
Dujardin la cavalière britannique au nom
très Français a remporté la médaille
d'or dans le Grand Prix spécial de
dressage déjà médaillée d'argent mardi
par équipe la double championne
olympique et la grande FA de l'épreuve
de reprise libre en musique qui aura
lieu demain après-midi les 15 meilleurs
cavaliers de dressage seront présents
parmi lesquels petite déception Erwan il
n'y a pas de français du dressage
également toute la journée en ouverture
cette fois du concours complet au Haras
du pain oui le concours complet c'est un
peu le triathlon de l'équitation trois
épreuves et on a tendance le cross et le
saut d'obstacle qui auront lieu plus
tard ça commence donc aujourd'hui par le
dressage au Haras du pain dans l'Orne et
là encore tous les regards étaient
braqués sur une Anglaise on la voit à
l'image elle s'appelle Zara Phillips
c'est tout simplement la petite fille de
la reine d'Angleterre Elizabeth II va
être déçu un quart Zara Philippe a
réalisé ce matin un passage très moyen
ça continue également en para dressage
le paradraissage ça se passe à
l'hippodrome de Caen devant des tribunes
il faut le dire toujours un peu vide
place ce matin au cavaliers handicapés
de grade 4 et déceptions pour la
française Nathalie Bizet qui a manqué
son passage et qui ne décrochera donc
pas la première médaille tant attendue
pour cette équipe de France d'équitation
merci Florent et ce midi on s'arrête
quelques instants sur cette discipline
du par adressage dessiné aux personnes
handicapées les preuves est tout aussi
technique que ça à grande soeur le
dressage une discipline qui permet
notamment aux anciens cavaliers valides
de poursuivre la compétition Pierre
Marie pure
il aime le défi Samuel Catel n'est pas
homme à refusé l'obstacle à l'âge de 17
ans son destin bascule fauché par une
voiture il perd sa jambe droite
je suis rentré chez moi au bout de 6
mois je suis monté à cheval comme ça au
début sans prothèse et puis c'est là où
je me suis dit il faut que je continue
c'est ça ma passion c'est ça mon
objectif et au bout de si moi je suis
qu'il fallait que je continue
le cheval l'a aidé à se relever
il a choisi le paradrait sage avec
l'ambition de redevenir un vrai cavalier
la compétition fut l'un des moteurs de
sa reconstruction
sur les concours même en classe B avec
des valides j'arrive à me classer
régulièrement sans problème donc
finalement le handicap il est là mais le
résultat il a aussi quoi
le parat dressage est une leçon
d'équilibre et de persévérance les
cavaliers sont classés par grade en
fonction de leur handicap
en 2010 alexington le paradressage a
fait son entrée dans le programme des
Jeux équestres mondiaux
c'est pas du tout une soudiscipline et
d'ailleurs quand on voit les les
médaillés au paralympique de Londres et
puis ceux qui font les meilleurs
performances au jeu équestre mondiaux en
Normandie et ben on verra que les
performances sont au niveau
de ce que peuvent faire des bons valides
chaque cavalier doit inventer son propre
langage pour se faire comprendre du
cheval
Samuel Catel mène sa monture sans
pouvoir s'appuyer sur sa jambe droite la
prothèse reste immobile c'est contraire
à toute règle de dressage
alors il a fallu compenser faire preuve
d'imagination
on peut faire exactement les mêmes
mouvements on peut faire les mêmes
choses et c'est aussi à nous entraîneurs
de trouver les biais de trouver les
subterfuges pour que le cheval comprenne
un codage un petit peu différent
quand je dois avoir des actions de ma
jambe droite comme c'est une prothèse et
qui est qu'elle est attachée à la sangle
je suis obligé de d'indiquer avec le
stick selon ce que je dois faire pour
changer de pub par exemple je mets un
petit coup sur l'épaule et c'est des
gestes à répéter répéter jusqu'à temps
qu'ils comprennent pour que ça devienne
de plus en plus fin en fait quand j'ai
mis reine bien ajuster comme ça je passe
mon style de derrière à l'avant et je
tape sur l'épaule et le cheval il dit ah
bon ok c'est ça que tu veux d'accord je
pense que les chevaux globalement sont
enclins à faire plaisir alors cavalière
c'est les mêmes techniques
d'entraînement que pour les valides
c'est la même exigence
ça reste du dressage de l'équitation
avant de parler de handicap
on ressent exactement les mêmes
sensations que tout cavalier après je
veux dire la différence pour moi pour
mon handicap vraiment c'est que je peux
pas courir je peux pas me déplacer
rapidement et ça gagne sur un cheval
c'est peut-être un sentiment un peu plus
de liberté de mouvement en avant
Patricia Nadou bonjour vous êtes membre
de l'association Handi et qui compète
vous êtes en charge des partenariats
dans cette association qui se charge de
la promotion du sport équestre pour les
handicapés la première difficulté pour
ces personnes ces cavaliers quand elles
veulent remonter à cheval j'imagine
c'est de réussir déjà à tenir sur le
cheval effectivement et tout dépend
d'abord bonjour et merci de me recevoir
sur plateau effectivement au tout dépend
bien sûr du handicap et du degré de
difficultés au niveau de la mobilité et
déjà tout d'abord avant de pouvoir
monter faire la compétition il faut déjà
pouvoir retrouver un accueil auprès d'un
établissement ou pouvoir avoir soi-même
l'aventure qui vous permettra de
recommencer le parat dressage c'est
parfois la possibilité pour d'anciens
cavaliers valide de reprendre la
compétition au niveau regardez c'est le
cas notamment de l'Autrichien pépouche
qui participait en 2004 aux Jeux
Olympiques d'Athènes chez les valides
mais en 2008 après une grave chute de
cheval il devient tétraplégique avant de
reprendre la compétition en para sur le
même cheval celui qui l'a fait tomber
Patricia Nadou reprendre la compétition
à haut niveau après une chute de cheval
c'est quelque chose qui arrive
régulièrement ça arrive parfois oui mais
par exemple exemple de pepo est quand
même j'irai un peu une histoire
exceptionnelle c'est à dire que il a
vécu déjà le très très haut niveau en
valide et c'est un compétiteur né et un
compteur dans l'âme donc ça c'est un
guerrier et pour lui c'était très très
important de revenir je pense dans le
circuit c'était l'adrénaline qui lui
manquait et comme j'expliquais je pense
que c'est quelqu'un qui va revenir plus
ou moins à la compétition mais qui va
évoluer il restera pas en grade un B en
France cette discipline du paradressage
commence tout juste finalement à ce à
s'organiser à se structurer nous sommes
structurés depuis réellement 2007 grâce
à la création de l'association handy et
qui compète qui au côté de la Fédération
française d'équitation de la Fédération
Française Handisport puisque le handicap
en France c'est la Fédération française
handisport qui gère et qui a des
fédérations maires et techniques avec
lesquelles pas des conventions pour pas
de médailles sur ces jeux équestre
mondiaux non pas de médaille parce que
nous avons des couples très très jeunes
alors pas jeunes dans l'expérience mais
jeune dans le binôme formé tous nos
cavaliers ont des chevaux cette année
depuis 7 à 8 mois maximum prometteur
donc ah oui oui là nous avons une équipe
de 6 cavaliers avec 6 excellents chevaux
et il faut perdurer fermer les
fermer les portes permettre des
partenariats entendu on est on les verra
sans doute au championnats d'Europe l'an
prochain à Deauville Merci à VOUS
Patricia Nadou d'avoir été sur ce
plateau du 12 13 ce midi pour nous
parler du Para dressage on va maintenant
faire un tour dans les allées du village
où l'on va retrouver ce midi Hélène
Jacques bonjour Hélène vous êtes en
compagnie d'une bête assez étrange je
crois et bien oui Erwan nous allons
parler aujourd'hui de zorse c'est le
diminutif du zèbre Horse cheval zorse
comme l'appel les Américains et je suis
avec Andy pousse un grand spécialiste de
l'éducation éthologique et puis avec
stormy c'est quoi ce croisement spatri
naturel quand même non non c'est pas
naturel c'est pas c'est un zèbre avec un
cheval et voilà on finit avec ça à
moitié cheval vous me disiez juste avant
c'est comme croisé un chien avec un loup
oui ben ça reste moitié sauvage donc je
fais ce que je peux mais elle reste
quand même
naturellement moitié sauvage alors ces
caractéristiques on voit bien les
rayures un peu partout et le caractère
aussi du zèbre c'est ça
après on peut faire énormément
d'éducation et c'est vraiment ça qui me
passionne mais c'est instinctivement
elle reste moitié zèbre alors on peut
vous voir tous les jours en
démonstration justement en train de
monter stormy l'idée c'est quoi c'est de
dire qu'on peut monter toutes sortes de
chevaux même assez exceptionnel en fait
c'est vraiment des expliqué que si on
suive toute le type d'apprentissage de
cette équidé même si c'est un équidé un
peu bizarre avec des rayures si on
comprend l'apprentissage on peut les
éduquer mais il faut déjà commence par
comprendre le cheval merci Andy donc
avoir tous les jours ici sur le village
des j'aime et je vous assure ça vaut le
coup Merci à VOUS Hélène notez que le
village des jeux à partir d'aujourd'hui
sera gratuit jusqu'à 14h dans la limite
de des 3000 places et qu'un billet pour
la compétition donne droit à l'accès au
village jusqu'à la fin des jeux une
autre discipline a fait son entrée hier
dans ces jeux équestres une discipline
en démonstration le horse ball qui ont
suivi Alexandra Hutin et Sylvain rude
quand on vous dit que ça ressemble au
basket c'est une réalité jusqu'au
pom-pom girl le horse-ball c'est un
véritable mélange de chaux et de sport
avant même l'entrée des équipes sur le
terrain ça chauffe dans les tribunes
faut monter la mayonnaise et qu'on
arrive après c'est chaud et ça nous
soutient
la magie du hors-ball c'est donc au-delà
de la technique et du couple homme
cheval alors bien sûr les initiés
apprécieront la vitesse la réactivité du
cavalier ça monture quand il faut
s'imposer pour aller marquer mais c'est
le jeu aussi qui captive c'est vivant ça
va beaucoup plus vite que le polo par
exemple c'est
les scènes de jeux sont faciles à
comprendre même pour des néophytes c'est
c'est comme un sport collectif comme du
basket comme du handball c'est facile à
appréhender et c'est très ludique et un
peu comme au running ici le public se
déride aucune comparaison possible avec
les disciplines-mères de l'équitation
j'ai moins aimé le dressage
une fois deux fois de cavaliers trois
cavaliers je m'ennuyais tandis que leurs
boules même si on connaît pas ça bouge
c'est sympathique et puis il y a les
speakers leur langage et le vocabulaire
qu'ils inventent s'en relâche le
hors-ball affiche complet dans les
tribunes pendant quatre jours maintenant
vous savez pourquoi
personne mon fort bonjour j'espère que
vous êtes n'aura pas manqué hors-ball
hier soir les jeux équestres continuent
avec vous cet après-midi sur France je
ne sais pas si je suis un expert mais en
tout cas je suis un passionné et
effectivement je partage tout à fait ce
qui vient d'être dit dans ce dans ce
sujet j'étais effectivement assez lot
hier soir et c'était une ferveur une
effervescence formidable pour l'une des
disciplines je pense les plus
spectaculaires de ces GEM certainement
cet après-midi à partir de 15h vous nous
parlez pas horse-ball je crois pas alors
on va peut-être parce que j'ai trouvé
votre sujet très bien fait si vous nous
y autorisez je pense que nous avons le
reprendre dans dans notre émission c'est
gentil en tout cas de la signaler c'est
effectivement des 15h05 en direction
avec de l'endurance j'imagine alors de
l'endurance ils imagtaient magnifiques
du Hans Ball et puis c'est
incontournable dressage dont on parle
pas mal depuis deux trois jours mais qui
demande tentant de compétences Merci à
VOUS Nelson Monfort on ne manquera pas
de vous suivre cet après-midi on en
profite pour saluer toute l'équipe de
France Télévisions qui nous accompagne
sur ces jeux équestres
ces jeux on peut également les retrouver
sur le site Internet de France 3
Basse-Normandie base tiret Normandie
France 3 point FR avec ce matin un
article sur les cavaliers français
engagés en raining cet après-midi à
laurening discipline très
impressionnante qui reprend avant la
grande finale de demain le 19 20 ce soir
en Basse-Normandie revient en direct de
ce jeu équestre mondiaux en
Haute-Normandie vous le sera présenté
par Frédéric Nicolas on se retrouve pour
notre part demain à la même place pour
ce 12 13 très bonne journée à vous et à
demain